now i don't know about you guys but i
really struggled with coming up with
presentation boards and mood boards
whilst i was at university i actually
procrastinated so much that i ended up
starting my own ecommerce brand
it was one way of distracting myself
from sitting down at the computer and
just mindlessly going through over and
over and over all sorts of different
mood board styles all sorts of different
presentation styles and trying to come
up with something that i thought the
tutors would find appealing
it was actually when i was doing my
e-commerce that i found canva now look
canva is definitely not the be-all
end-all for creating architectural
presentation documents but it was such
an incredible tool that actually changed
my life and saved me so much time so
today i thought because a lot of you
guys have been asking in the private
discord chat there is a link down below
if you want to join it
about how i created my presentation
boards back at university now before we
go any further i do want to preface this
video with there is a tracking link down
below that's because i reached out to
canva a couple weeks ago and we struck a
deal
now i want to make it very clear before
you click away from this video canva is
actually 100 free you don't have to pay
for a single thing you sign up you
create an account and you can do pretty
much 99 of the things they do have a
premium plan that allows you to access
an extensive library of content which is
fantastic but it isn't 100 required i
only gained some sort of commission out
of this if you purchase a premium plan
now having said that at the same time i
know deep down that you are given a
30-day free trial my tracking link only
accepts some sort of commission if you
sign up within the first 30 days
so basically what i'm saying is i'm
doing this out of the goodness of my
heart because even if you do go out and
buy a premium plan you're most likely
going to sign up to the first 30 days as
a free trial
because why wouldn't you and then after
that i gained nothing out of it
nonetheless i do genuinely believe in
canberra i have genuinely used it for
the past
i don't know seven eight years however
long it's been since i've been at
university it has been a phenomenal tool
to be able to be
accessed so quickly and change so
quickly i ended up creating my resume on
it it got me my first job i ended up
creating all sorts of digital mood
boards and i even created an e-commerce
book that was part of one of my first
businesses so everything that you think
you can do on photoshop you can probably
do it quicker on canva okay so i wanted
to show you guys today exactly what
canva is about what qualities are on
here and what we can really do with
canva as you can see i've created my
ecommerce books down below which i will
link down below if you're interested in
any way shape or form i've also created
all the instruction booklets and the
checklists that are on my website so to
this day i am still genuinely using
canva as a great tool and great
accessory to basically creating quick
digital design packages and presentation
boards i've already logged in i've
already got my account so what you're
seeing here is if you were to sign up
and join canva for 100 free at the top
you'll see templates which showcase a
whole bunch of different professional
utilities that you can actually use in
your day-to-day life anything from
social media through to business now
personally when i'm looking for
something architecture related i tend to
go to the infographics page here at the
top in the templates and scroll through
this to get some inspiration i like the
infographics because for the very simple
reason i usually create these sorts of
documents for an informative purpose
they aren't so much for presenting
drawings anymore as they used to be they
are purely now just for creating and
presenting all sorts of different ideas
and concepts in the workplace so as you
can see in this template folder there is
a hundred million different
ideas and templates that you can
basically choose from and they're
stupidly simple to edit and change so
let's scroll up and pick a completely
random one let's go
writing for tv let's go customize this
document and let me just explain how
simple it is to use canva
now if i was to export it i'd get
exactly this as it's showcased and shown
on screen it would be a pdf that i could
change the size and dimensions of or i
can simply go through and actually just
change everything as i see fit so let's
say i wanted it to really represent my
brand a little bit more i wanted it to
be
a bit more genuine in the space and i
didn't want it to
seem like none of it actually matched
whatsoever i could go through change the
colors that quickly that easily on any
of these diagrams double click on the
text and just start typing anything that
i wanted
it is genuinely that easy to update if i
wanted to zoom in to see what i was
actually doing i could zoom in by using
the zoom tool
zoom out very similar to photoshop on
the left hand side you have a whole
bunch of elements so anything that
you're looking for anything that you're
trying to actually implement and change
you can literally just drag and drop a
chart directly into it now if i was
creating some sort of infographic and i
wanted the percentage to be more or less
simply dragging around these sliders
changing bits and pieces will
very simply
allow me to get my brand detailing in to
how i specifically like it now
again if i didn't want that there
reshape resize drag and drop as you can
see i've uploaded plenty of my own
previous information to be able to
generate
text and imagery as i wanted it to you
can even upload all sorts of different
text
fonts everything is free everything is
easy to use if you do stumble upon a
paid feature so for example if i come
into elements
scroll up there's a couple paid graphics
here so this is where canva really
excels with good quality graphics you
obviously have heaps of free versions
like this couch but if you wanted to
upgrade to a completely different couch
then you would actually have to pay
an upgraded fee now as you can see i've
changed that color to light gray so you
can actually see it and it will be
blanked out with the canva watermark if
i wanted to remove the watermark i'd
have to either pay a one dollar fee or i
could simply join canva pro now as i'm
editing this video i've realized that i
didn't actually mention any of the links
in the description box below
if you guys want to check them out there
is some great content for all sorts of
architects architecture students or
anybody in the industry there's links
down below to all the digital downloads
which feature
for example construction checklist to
help you guide what you need to have on
a set of construction drawings there's
also archicad title blocks down there
and i've even put the e-commerce book
that i talked about on this video below
that you'll find the canva link and you
will also find the discord group chat if
you're in the industry any way shape or
form practicing professional or student
please feel free to join the group chat
it is a collective of people that is
genuinely just trying to help each other
grow and improve as much as we can
there's plenty of people on there that
know way more than me about archicad and
architecture in general and i'm so
grateful that those people have joined
and contributing to this community so if
you are interested just take a look at
the description box down below check out
all the different links and see how they
can benefit you in hopefully one way
shape or form if i wanted to create
something a little bit more
architectural so let's close out of that
and close out of that and come back to
our home page you'll see that the
template i was working on is thrown into
my recents i'm going to delete that
because i don't need that i'll showcase
you something that i created this ebook
i created in under one hour and it is
the redacted version of the paid version
so i'm not going to give all the way all
the secrets away straight away but
basically i've created a whole ebook
that has a million and one different
little bits and pieces little different
infographics and just overlay after
overlay after overlay that genuinely
would have taken me three or four days
to create via photoshop indesign
illustrator if not even longer to go
through and create every single one of
these little graphics it just wouldn't
have been worth the time to go and
create all of these little icons all of
these little people it it just makes so
much more sense to do it through
something like canva that already has
all that information on there and it's
literally drag drop move click change
the color of the cloud i want it to be
green it doesn't take a lot of knowledge
to be able to use this program and
that's why i found it so useful
so practical especially now in the real
world even if we go back to something
like the working drawings checklist i'll
give you guys a little glimpse this is
available to download at my store but
this is basically the first free glimpse
you'll ever get on my channel but
basically i created this on here
instead of creating it via photoshop or
indesign because it's just so simple i
can click on one of my images i can link
it directly to my site i can click on
one of the icons
for social media link it directly to my
youtube channel and not have to go back
in to pdf pro
and then actually individually link
every single bit and piece it's just so
simple and so easy to use that it makes
any document creation regardless of it's
a presentation board a simple mood board
a pdf document or whatever you're trying
to create just genuinely so easy to make
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video today's video was
definitely less of a tutorial and a
little bit more of a general resource
that you guys can go out and use any
time of day it is so simple to use that
i don't think i need to create an
in-depth tutorial if you think i do
please leave a comment down below and i
will definitely create some sort of
tutorial for you guys to be able to
actually understand canva a lot better
if there is anything else you want to
see as always leave the comment down
below and please remember to smash the
like button because the like button
actually helps with the youtube
algorithm believe it or not and also if
you enjoyed this content please smash
the subscribe button so i know that you
guys are enjoying this content and i
should create more of it more often but
anyway that is all from me today like
always i'll see you next monday